[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is popping everyone welcome to the
mix 10th year anniversary showcase i am
your host justin woodward co-founder of
the mix
the media in the exchange black voices
gaming indie team in terra bank
entertainment and an advisor on the
humble black game developer fund i am
with my amazing co-host candice mckinney
what is up candy hey justin and hey
everybody out there my name is candace
and i am so excited to be here
co-hosting the 10th anniversary mix
showcase thank you so much for having me
that's right candy this marks 10 years
and it's been an amazing journey we went
from our first showcase in the cafeteria
at ign and then expanded to showcases
around the world during 2020 we
completely shifted to virtual events
garnering millions of views each year
that is so impressive justin you know
the mix team has accomplished so much so
today we are going to celebrate we've
got over 80 games to show you we're
going to be highlighting different
genres
new and gameplay titles from black game
developers throughout our black voices
and gaming feature
before we get started we have to give a
huge shout out to all of our sponsors
limited run games raw fury razor for
providing the pcs for the production and
more we also want to give a huge shout
out to intel for the intel gamedev boost
program and thanks to all of the
industry and publishing sponsors who
helped make this showcase possible want
to thank the devs and publishers acapura
games the symbol entertainment critical
reflex draw distance goblins graffiti
games hype train digital merge modern
wolf movie games neon doctrine noodle
cake tiny builds
white thorn games and all the developers
who are participating we also want to
thank our broadcasting partners ig and
gamespot steam and twitch you guys are
amazing
you guys we've also teamed up with valve
to showcase games on the stream in order
to support the devs be sure to check out
the mix 10th anniversary showcase page
on steam where you can learn more about
the games buy games that are available
now or add games to your wish list for
ones that haven't been released yet
wishlists really helped the devs so
let's make it happen definitely
pre-order the games wish list the games
that definitely helps enough with the
long-winded intro let's hop into our
first set of games with a first look
into a fun action adventure game that is
reminiscent of miyazaki's masterpiece
kiki's delivery service and we also have
a new announcement of a game called in
stars and time as well as the world
premiere of cassette beast from raw fury
let's get started let's go
[Music]
huh
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
shine
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
feelings
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi i'm alexey audio director on tinykim
in our last video we talked about the
storylines and characters you'll meet in
the world of tinykin
today let's talk about sound and music
[Music]
dining is a game about being small and
getting very close to things we all know
you have worked on carpets art showers
and picked up cardboard so it's a great
opportunity to make something that feels
very familiar
milo can step on everything in this big
world
so each motor yard needs to have its own
audio feedback not only that but each
environment in the house has unique
acoustics
so standing inside a tv will feel as
huge as it does to an ants
we are also going the extra mile with
music in tiny king
every room of the house has its own
musical theme
and each one has many instrumental
versions according to your position in
that huge space
as milo explores the living room you'll
hear the living room theme
but when he enters inside the piano to
save a lost ant
the music will seamlessly blend to the
piano version of the living room
and inside the guitar the guitar living
room theme
even the church has its own vision
[Music]
each room has more than five musical
versions to help them feel like full
living societies
last but not least voices milo's
abilities are represented by living
creatures named the tiny king
they each have slightly different
personalities so they have to sound
unique
[Music]
same goes for the npcs
silver fish and dung beaters are very
different people in this world
so they need to have voices that
represent their identities
i managed to record and perform every
voices in the game so far
that's a very funny way to make them
alive
we are still working hard on tinykey so
stay tuned for our next videos
hey there we're back it only took us
five years but it's finally here
rumor die is coming to nintendo's switch
if you're looking for a family-friendly
yet picked up party game this is it get
together with your close ones and ruin
some friendships with one single rule
move or die when it comes to multiplayer
you can play online local wireless or
even move or die on the go pick from
over a hundred characters and dive into
50 plus game modes and if you want a
challenge throw in some mutators to
spice things up but let's be honest
that's mostly marketing talk so let me
rephrase
six whole years worth of updates packed
into the best friendship ruining game
move or die
out now on nintendo switch
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow those first set of games
chefs kiss i have been anticipating
soundfall since their crowdfunding
campaign on fig and it looks fantastic
meek in the witches mountain looks
magical and gives me the warm and
fuzzies
well speaking of the warm and fuzzies
justin up next is a segment of
family-friendly games starting with the
world premiere of a new multiplayer
narrative driven rpg called paladins
let's check it out can't wait
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hi there faith game designer at sea by
seed studio we are happy to present you
our second game paladins is a narrative
adventure inspired by type of rpgs and
playable with up to four friends online
you play as buskers who have the epic
task of entertaining a mythical beast if
you like choose your own adventure books
and board games then this might be a
good fit for you you can subscribe to
our newsletter to keep up with the info
[Music]
you are little gator
fall is here and you're back on the
island your favorite place in the world
you can practically see the wonderful
memories come to life all around you
the best part is big sis is here too
there's just one problem she's still
stuck in her schoolwork
there's only one way to get her to play
with you you've got to remind her how
things used to be
[Music]
in little gator game you'll explore
every corner of the beautiful island on
the lake
[Music]
thanks to the help of your best friends
there are hats to wear terrible monsters
to beat and new pals all over the place
if you want to impress big sis you'll
need all the paws you can get
[Music]
friends are in grave danger
others not so much
[Music]
actually it looks like that other guy
was fine too
[Music]
oops
don't worry you always have the chance
to make things right
[Music]
this bunny's craftsmanship will make a
great addition to the playground
[Music]
now that you've got all this paper time
for some arts and crafts those quests
gave you a bunch of great ideas
how about a new hat or a new sword or a
new shield
there's no better way to bring color to
the
world all right you've got your new gear
now what
why don't you
sled down a hill as fast as you can
scale sheer rocks that only a kid would
dare and go higher with every bracelet
you find
get a bird's bird's-eye view by gliding
across the island
don't worry about all that water gators
know how to swim
uh-oh looks like you might be lost
it's cool just head for something tall
you'll find your way again in no time
and what's the harm in getting lost
anyway there are all sorts of cool
secret spots to find
with all this heroism there's no way big
sis can say no
at least that's what we hope
[Music]
there's an island full of wonder
adventure and friendship waiting for you
in a little gator game
[Music]
coming to pc and nintendo switch 2022
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to camp canyonwood
where campers learn valuable survival
skills
like wood shopping
archery
and fishing
and where nothing strange
ever happens
and the best part is we're now hiring
build up and restore camp canyonwood to
its former glory
and give our campers the summer they'll
never forget
there's so much going on in my head
sometimes i imagine a simple donut
factory floating in the clouds just to
help me sort out my thoughts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
will you help me
neca ghost jump is an action puzzle
platformer that takes place on neko
world and before we get into gameplay i
wanted to go over some of the backstory
for the game
here we have deco man proposed to neca
girl
uh-oh
those daggone space dog pirates seem
like trouble
and sure are they crashed they come in
that girl's wedding
no
our two main mechanics are coming up
quickly here
first the ability to switch between 2d
and 3d camera perspectives at any time
then there's the ability to switch
between the physical form and ghost form
which is very versatile
you'll see here that instead of losing a
life for a coin the ghost horn can be
used as either a sacrifice or with some
good timing just an extension and easily
return back to the body it's also useful
when finding hidden loot and other
things in the ghost realm
[Music]
there are multiple vials each with their
own share of dangers and new ways to
rethink how the main mechanics work
here's another advantage of the ghost
form being able to deflect projectiles
back to enemies
here's our first sneak peek the pirate
ship biome which will wrap up the story
campaign for neca ghost junk we'll have
eight main campaign bombs along with
additional optional ones available at
launch
[Music]
here's our second super sneaky sneak
peek which is super hot off the bug
squashing line
neck and ghost jump run flawlessly on
the nintendo switch
thanks so very much for watching please
consider picking up the game on steam or
epic game store today it's currently in
early access or if you're not sold on it
just yet throw us a wish list
if you don't game on the pc be on the
lookout for the game on your favorite
console system
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
hi everyone my name is saffron and i'm
the creative director at kitten cap
studio
hi i'm justin i'm the lead programmer
and today we're going to introduce you
to our game about tea making for cats
pico
so in this gameplay video we'll be
introducing ourselves to min who will
teach us how to make blooming tea
there she is she's so
cute minh is an elderly cat living in
pika who runs her tea house with the
help of her grand goddaughter poncha
she also mentions chaiwon the previous
owner of your tea house whose story
you'll uncover as you play through the
game
now that we've introduced ourselves and
men let's make some tea
[Music]
so in this tutorial min is going to walk
us through the basics of making blooming
tea which is her specialty
uh cats can teach the player new styles
and recipes for making tea which they
can then use in their own tea shop or on
their own
[Music]
what you're seeing here is one of the
starter tea sets the cute tea set and
it's one of the many tea sets you'll be
able to use to make tea in this game
i really like this pea set
so one of our inspirations
for pico is
anime so our glass teapot also looks a
little bit anime-like as well and as you
can see when you pick up and move
objects around that they'll have a
little bit of a squash and stretch to
them as well so that they feel a little
bit more fun
you can see that the water is boiled and
ready to go
so you can go ahead and pour the water
in
the glass teapot is a really good fit
for this type of tea because you can see
the blooming happening inside of it
and now that we're done we can present
our tea to men and see what she thinks
[Music]
and it looks like she likes it
and that's the end of our tea tutorial
with men
look forward to hearing more about our
development through our twitter
newsletter or our discord which is up on
the screen
and don't forget to wishlist pico on
steam
thank you thank you
[Music]
meet doug
your typical animal lover and shelter
employee
but when he discovers his local shelter
is on the brink of foreclosure he needs
to make some cash and fast
fortunately there's a new job
opportunity available
problem is
doug's the world's worst handyman
he should never be anywhere near a
hammer
while he's trying his best to fix items
he's causing more damage than repairs
he'll need your help to find the right
tools to complete tasks
all while dodging workplace hazards
[Music]
can you pull it off and save the shelter
or are you
chicken
[Music]
definitely feeling the warm and fuzzies
with that last selection of games kind
of reminds me of our friends over at
wholesome games right yeah shout out to
wholesome they always give me the
warming buzzes for sure our next set of
games will be town builders sim and deck
building games we have a world premiere
title called these doomed islands and
the world premiere of four tails let's
shuffle our decks hoard our resources
and check out this next set of games
word
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
hi i'm matic from quite okay games and
today i would like to show you the very
first gameplay preview of our upcoming
game lysara summit kingdom the game is a
challenging city builder set in high
mountains where you have to build a new
home for your kin first out of lowlands
here we have a small village we can
expand it's located quite low in a zone
rich in vegetation and fertile lands so
it's a great place for growing crops
barley which you can get from farms can
be then transported to a yak powered
mill for the production of sampa a kind
of flower sampak can be then distributed
to your citizens via marketplace
besides food we also have to take care
of the spirituality of our folks
placing shrines makes the people living
nearby happier and reaching certain
happiness thresholds enables upgrading
houses which will now accommodate more
residents giving you work workforce at
your disposal
this small village consists entirely of
commoners but there are two more social
castes in our game lowlanders and monks
finding the balance between the casts
and satisfying the various needs of
their members is not all you will have
to do in the game in a harsh and
difficult mountain environment you will
have to build transportation
infrastructure
deal with avalanche
hazards survive weather breakdowns
and in the end rise a summit temple on
the very peak of the mountain
and that's all we've got to show you
today the game will be launching on
steam later this year so if you like
what you saw you can add lysara summit
kingdom to your wishlist thanks and see
you next time
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
hi there i'm andrew the creative lead
here at triple vision games in the uk
i'm really excited to announce today our
new game these doomed isles
these doomed isles is inspired by
classic god games survival city builders
and roguelike deck builders
you'll use your godly powers to raise
islands from the sea
you'll build settlements for your
devoted followers and make sure that
they remain devoted and alive by keeping
them warm fed sheltered and safe
you'll harvest new cards for your deck
to better face the challenges ahead of
you because remember
these are doomed isles
defend your island from raiders hell
bent on seeing your settlement reduced
to rubble
survive natural disasters including
those of your own making
face decay
famine
and your ultimate destruction
do you have what it takes to survive
these doomed dials
so that was our first look at these doom
dials exclusive here on the mix
now
as a small team
getting feedback from players throughout
development is a vital part of what's
going to make this game as good as it
can be
so we're planning to run a series of
closed alphas throughout the year
you'll find the link to sign up on our
steam page
which we just launched about 10 minutes
ago
so if you like what you saw head on over
there
while you're there give that wishlist
button a little tap and also please sign
up for the closed alpha so that you can
play a part in building these doomed
aisles
okay bye bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
nice
[Music]
[Music]
hi i'm jared the community manager at
nariel and we are thrilled to be showing
card shark at the mix in our depiction
of 18th century france gambling salons
are all the rage but you'll need to play
your opponents better than you play your
cards we've built our game around
cheating techniques that can be
performed in real life deck switches
mark cards sleight of hand trickery and
deception those are the tools at your
disposal and as a special treat for the
mix we have an exclusive gameplay
premiere our lead artist and a card
trickster himself nikolai troshinsky
will explain how one of the techniques
in our game is performed
there are many ways to cheat in a game
of cards in card shark we try to show as
many of them as possible
in this scene you have two goals
to gain knowledge of your opponent's
strongest card and to make sure they
have at least one weak card in their
hand
having stolen the deck with the help of
your accomplice
you can now leave to mark the cards in
secret
[Music]
there are countless ways to mark a deck
of cards
a real cheat will use his own system
so that only he can read it
you can mark the cards any way you want
you can get creative
we are going to mark the cards using
simple lines in clockwise order
from ace to king to queen to jack
that should be easy enough for us to
recognize later
we don't want to take too long as the
longer we're away from the table the
more suspicious it gets
now it's time to return and pour the
comp another glass of wine so that he
can retrieve the deck from our pocket
we still need to force a low card for
our opponent
we'll steal this 10 of spades from our
hand
wait for our turn to deal and add it to
the top of the deck
now we can deal it and as we deal we are
watching for our marking
right there that's a jack
we need to recognize them quickly if we
take too long it will start to look
suspicious
there's another one that's an ace
and the queen finally we use our secret
code to tell our accomplice the highest
card and that's how we make the come to
win
we don't want to win ourselves to not
draw too much attention and there you
have it one of the many tricks that you
can perform in card shark and in real
life our demo is available on steam
right now and card shark will be coming
to steam a nintendo switch later this
year
[Music]
so
would you like to know the fate of the
realm
good then let's begin
first pick a card
aha the thief
you know i once heard a story about a
thief and his friend
who were asked to steal a magical liar
but it was heavily guarded
[Music]
and it wasn't exactly smart to attack
the guards head-on so
they had to get creative
now you're getting it
but no sooner had they gotten their
hands on the liar and the thief began to
have terrifying visions of the end of
the world
and he knew that the only way to escape
it was to gather his companions and set
off on a voyage into the unknown
and then
well
what happens next is entirely up to you
[Music]
four tales a card-based narrative
journey
hey oracles i'm buddy the community
manager for akupara games and today i'd
like to introduce you to the core
gameplay of estrella six sided oracles a
dice deck building roguelike by little
leo games in estrella the two
fundamental forces you'll be balancing
are purification and corruption
purification is blue and corruption red
in the game's kind of color terms
purifying a good guy like me or my
sentinels is going to heal them while
corruption damages them likewise
purification damages my opponents and
corruption heals them the goal of the
game is to purify your enemies before
you are corrupted entirely and and by
the way in case you're wondering no no
animals are hurt in the process of
purification you know like once i purify
this little guy he's just gonna give a
give a hop get the hell out of here
and it's this duality where estrella
really ticks for instance there are
going to be times when i'm going to want
to use corruption on myself rather than
heal my enemies right and it's also
important to note that taking damage is
going to activate these which are called
virtues this virtue for instance will
let me draw a die but i have to take
five points of corruption in order to
activate it which you know this makes me
consider whether i want to use this
purified dye to heal me or to deal
damage to my enemy which is where the
dice come in when you're playing
estrella you'll have a dice pool which
is essentially your deck or you know
maybe it's better to think of it like a
dice bag like in d d where each turn
you're going to reach in pick a certain
number of random dice and then roll them
the die faces you end up with are kind
of like your hand for that turn
and just like a normal deck builder as
you move through battles you're going to
be adding dice to your dice pool over
time the interesting hitch though is
that when you win a battle you'll be
prompted to add a safe die a balanced
die or a risky die to your dice pool
and a risky die is nice because it will
have very powerful positive effects but
the drawbacks are going to be
significant too part of the strategy
that goes into estrella is balancing the
consistency of safe dice with the raw
power of risky dice if you play it too
safe you're not going to be able to
close out fights against tougher enemies
playing it too risky and you'll end up
corrupting yourself before the enemy
even has a chance to
anyway there is plenty more when it
comes to talking about estrella like the
game's six different characters with
their own unique mechanics but all of
that is a little down the line for now
if you'd like to learn more about
estrella please feel free to come hang
out with me in the estrella discord and
otherwise i hope you have a great time
at the mix cheers
so
you've chosen the life of a legitimate
small business owner wise decision
you're going to need to make sure you're
set up for success on your journey to
run a chain of definitely legal thriving
businesses
first you're going to need somewhere to
grow dry and store your product a dry
den sounds like it'll do the job just
fine
the best product needs tended to by the
best hands so make sure you hire top
quality employees to look after your
stash
word on the street is your product is
the best in town now if i happen to be a
hungry little competitor i'd sure be
trying to get my hands on some of it
better make sure your employees are
armed to the teeth and ready to protect
that cash money
you're going to want to set up a front
and you just also happen to be somewhat
of a connoisseur of chicken
as well as well you know
as an upstanding member of the community
it's important you build lasting mutual
relationships with the locals i hear the
university might have quite the appetite
might be worthwhile checking in at the
scrap yard too
now it's time to expand baby why stop at
chicken donuts nightclubs casinos
laundromats and it only makes sense to
expand your product line too right
and from there it's time to reap the
sweet sweet fruits of your labor look at
you you upstanding entrepreneurial
contributor to society
definitely not fried chicken for all
your legitimate fake business needs
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
doing
[Music]
it is so great to revisit lacera summit
kingdom from the winter mix fix it is
looking gorgeous and a breath of fresh
air technically and also these doomed
owls is a fascinating twist on the city
building genre yeah it's like tetris
pieces and cars it's it's so dope so
much creativity all around candy i know
how much you dig big rigs in the dream
of gassing up an 18 wheeler and heading
cross country so we're gonna do just
that and head into this heaping helping
of truck simulation games you're right
justin i do love a big rig let's go
[Music]
hi everyone we at truck world studio are
excited to reveal the first gameplay of
our upcoming game truck world australia
today we're going to introduce some of
the basic gameplay mechanics which make
our game stand out from other driving
simulators but first let's put the radio
off
in truck world you can interact with
almost every part of your cabin right
now we're arriving in a warehouse to
pick up the load here's the trailer
which we'll need to hook up
we believe that in truck world australia
everyone should get an opportunity to
feel like a professional truck driver so
players can enable visual hints for a
more convenient experience
and now here's why truck world is
different from other truck simulation
games
let's leave the cab to complete some
final steps
let's make sure the load is secured
take off support brakes
and attach the cable
looks like we're ready to start
with the trailer attached you'll need to
be very careful with turns
that's it for today if you enjoy the
progress make sure to wish list and
follow truck world australia on steam
and in socials we'll have more news to
share very soon
see you
now that is my kind of game i cannot
wait to go
and live out all of my trucking
fantasies in real time truth be told
that was a crazy long segment up next
we're going to get into our pixel bag
and pop into some new 2d throwback games
with a release date announcement of
soldiers as well as a brand new world
premiere trailer for a chaotic and silly
boxing joint bare butt boxers bbb what
can't wait to see those bare butt boxers
in action let's go
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everybody
i'm jason i'm the developer of akrita
the game that you see before you
this is craig
hey how's it going i'm craig
um i'm also craig and i do the music
and uh so today we're showing off a
totally new island in this game the game
is full of
unique islands where each one has a
theme and special mechanics
that are full of puzzles
uh this is the volcano
uh the view one of the unique mechanics
on this island are these lava cracks so
you see craig walking over
and it as you step across them that
builds up heat until you
burn up and die so you kind of have to
plan your route once you step off of the
lava you cool off and you're safe
and uh
each island has a special block that's
unique to each island so in this case
there's these metal blocks that
once you heat them up enough
they
get primed like a bomb like a kind of
traditional zelda game type of bomb so
as you can see there he used it to blow
up that wooden block that was in his way
to get that ruby
and um each island has they got excited
yep got too excited be careful
you have to find the right path um
then yeah so once you get enough gems
then you bring them to the god of each
island
another
unique thing on this island that craig
has just found
are these angry fire spirits that are
defending the island um and so there are
puzzles
where this
spirit is trying to kill you so you have
to um
yeah he tried to bomb you
that's pretty difficult and when you
defeat each one it becomes even more
difficult
until you defeat the third one and then
there's like a very cool item that you
get when you do that but we will
reveal that today that's for the players
to discover
uh yeah so then if you go to the right
and then you go up
so craig has six gems now so he's gonna
go visit the god the volcano god
and unlock
something new that guy looks awesome
thank you
and uh yeah so what
are these
it's awoken
these little fire dudes and um we won't
reveal what they do today the players
will find out but there's lots of stuff
in this game like this where
you discover something new and you have
to experiment with it to find out what
it does
thanks for joining us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
we just follow the path
[Music]
before trouble found us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for her daughter's spirit has been
locked away
[Music]
uh
[Music]
do
boom
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
hyper gun sport is all about arcade
action precision shooting and tight
jumps clutch saves and epic slams but
the only thing you can shoot is the ball
it's cyberpunk volleyball with guns jump
in with your favorite gun sport team the
fire and ice of neo tokyo the wily old
timers from blue cambodia impressive
upstarts from people's republic of
oakland the precise team from the new
republic of congo the cybernetic heart
of uwsd and more each with something to
prove to the world
teams are composed of two positions
strikers move and jump but have fewer
shots available keepers stay entrenched
in front of the goal with the wider
aiming range and more shots fill your
gauge with explosive focus attacks and
unlock special weapons for tricky
bounces and friendly action
and if that's not enough battle it out
across seven unique arenas each loaded
with its own gimmicks from goals that
open and close or change point values to
moving nets and even unstable footing
players of all stripes we've got your
back hyper gunsport comes loaded with
numerous accessibility options so you
can play the game the way you want to
play turn on aim assist adjust laser
length tweak the game's feed to your
liking or even disable the background
for added visibility as long as you're
having fun we're having fun too the
frenetic action doesn't stop there the
officially sanctioned rules aren't the
only way to play think you've got what
it takes to be the best change things up
at the start of a match by choosing any
of the 10 plus totally unique rule sets
try underwater for a funky slow jam of
strikes and saves big bounce for more
bounce to the ounce
hot potato for one gold takes all action
and so many more
[Music]
you've got the mechanics down so can you
step into the spotlight blast your way
through circuit mode an eight round
tournament for one to two players and
learn more about your team's motivations
for winning the world's game do so to
unlock alt outfits and arenas
up to four friends can also play in
local versus mode speaking of friends we
are so excited to announce the addition
of steam remotes play together
friends or frenemies couldn't make it
over for couch co-op no problems connect
online for some fast-paced gunsport
actions
for the passion and the fame it's two
guns against the world hyper gun sport
is coming soon to a system near you
you can join the hyper gun sport
community today over on discord
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
boxers and blossom tales too so many
bees and so many pixels they have an
amazing style and a classic throwback
neo retro vibe all of the games look so
fun they really do justin now before we
move to our next segment we want to
remind you to check out the games in the
mixed steam page wish lists the games
you like show the devs some love and
play their demos if they're available it
really helps the devs out make sure to
do the damn thing for the next segment
if you're into classic tactics strategy
as well as rpgs this is the segment for
you we have a world premiere
announcement and trailer from a game
titled vanaris from our friends at toge
productions as well as a release date
and announcement for contada beef up
your party's gear and get ready to party
with some of the best strategy and
role-playing games that have yet to come
boom can't wait
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
around the world the giant monsters
known as kaiju are made monster attacks
collapsed on the new scientists
[Music]
we must plan carefully
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the kaiju are powerful
but predictable
[Music]
open fire
yeah
it's not enough
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
hello adventurers i'm buddy the
community manager for akupara games and
today i'd like to dive deep into the
gameplay of absolute tactics daughters
of mercy our upcoming turn-based tactics
rpg from curious fate games
now if you haven't seen absolute tactics
before the core game captures that
classic turn-based rpg experience you've
got cool characters who level up equip
items and have skills and abilities it's
the basics right but the thing that sets
absolute tactics apart from you know
some of its contemporaries is taking a
different approach to classes which is
really what i want to dig into today how
do classes work in absolute tactics
well they're items a class handbook is a
piece of equipment that you can give
directly to one of your characters just
like you would give them a sword or a
staff except a class handbook is going
to radically change the way they
approach the battlefield while you won't
be able to completely redesign your
character from the ground up because
each character has their own unique
skills abilities and attack pattern the
lion's share of their role in a fight
will come from their class handbooks
and by the way every character in
absolute tactics can dual class which is
to say each character can equip two
different class handbooks at the same
time each class handbook is going to
give that character a certain set of
passive stats and active abilities so
the berserker for instance increases
your basic attack damage and gives you a
powerful melee attack while the sorcerer
increases your ability damage and gives
you a powerful range spell strike
the different class handbooks can also
be leveled up themselves a rank 1
berserker handbook only gives you 8
attack in the berserking ability but a
rank 3 berserking handbook will give you
10 attack the berserking ability the
carnage ability and the ferocity ability
the special tomes that are used to
upgrade handbooks are a really powerful
reward that you might have to dig around
for a little bit to kid out your whole
team
but berserker and sorcerer are really
just the tip of the iceberg you can also
be a botanist and summon bushes with
healing berries or an entomologist to
summon a swarm of cicadas to debuff your
enemies or a courier whose whole thing
is just moving around and delivering
packages which means absolute tactics
has this prismatic array of
possibilities for you to use to
customize your characters in your party
and that's about it for an introduction
to class handbooks i'll be doing some
deep dives on individual classes a
little bit later down the line so feel
free to join the akupara games discord
if you want to keep up to date on all
things absolute tactics otherwise i hope
you have a great time at the mix cheers
if i told you what i've seen
would you even believe me
i've seen empires rise and fall
and spoken with gods
sights beyond comprehension
but i don't need to convince you
you can see for yourself
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
we were not ready for their divine
judgment
we were tested
and almost everyone
just failed
their dark mysticism shattered an era of
enlightenment
and ushered in the dusk
of the 21st century
billions of lives were lost in a
heartbeat
turned to ash
and cast away in the wind
our soldiers were gone
but our weapons kept fighting
driven by an enigma in the networks
their surviving forces waged a desperate
crusade against the machines
we
became bystanders
to a relentless war
now our world is an ever twisting
nightmare
hellish threats lurk in every whisper
and shadow
there is no glory
only survival
deliver us from this trial
reclaim our world
for mankind
[Music]
hi my name is julia and as a community
manager of gatewalkers game i am proud
to tell you a little bit more about it
gatewalkers is a cooperative action rpg
what makes it special is survival
elements which are extremely important
during the game
you're playing as a gatewalker
you are the warrior and you want to save
your dying world
to do that you have to travel through
various words using a portal
every word is procedurally generated
which means the map changes each time
you visit the world
looting and gathering will help you to
craft better equipment and new items
you will need a good weapon to fight
different bosses animals and monsters
you can play the game solo or team app
with up to three friends and as a team
begin your journey
the core element of the gameplay is
combat
it is truly skill based
you need to aim at your target with a
spell and you can dodge spells cast at
your enemies
during your quests you can choose from
multiple solo combos or use different
passive spells
finally if you are playing in a team you
can cast powerful combos together
in gatewalkers there are no predefined
classes each item gives you unique set
of skills
you can mix them to create your own
unique character
remember
you are what you wear
during your travels you will visit
places with specific terrain
climate creatures and also resources
you have to survive freezing blizzards
wild monsters scorching sun the darkness
toxic fumes
but it is just the beginning
you have to prepare yourself gather
resources and avoid dehydration or
starvation
that ends this short introduction to the
game i hope you like it
don't forget to add gatewalkers to your
wishlist on steam and follow us on
social media channels
don't be afraid of portals
become a gatewalker
and we're back i love turn-based tactics
so much that are reminiscent of console
classics like disgaea and final fantasy
tactics so so excited to see fresh takes
on the genre for sure i agree with you
this next segment we're going to pull
out our bfgs
stat guns and grab our flashlights the
segment is dedicated to hardcore
shooters and games filled with survival
and action-based horror we're going to
load up in the world premiere of the new
iteration of mother gunship and then
lock into the world premiere of
slacation paradise
let's go
the indy hit first person shooter now
even more first person
welcome back recruit you do something
different with your hair
you know the deal aliens earth
let's blow stuff up
come on that's all you got
that won't get you out of this recruit
but upgrades might build the weapon of
your dreams
oh who's gonna go boom boom oh you are
intuitive and powerful
you got friends bring them and die
i mean fight together
oh no no
okay end up too much
no that's just
seriously
i'm starting to think this was a bad
idea
[Music]
are you tired of going on the same old
boring holidays
too expensive or not enough activities
for the whole family
not anymore
introducing
[Music]
slaycation paradise we provide
everything you need to break free from
reality
visit our many unique and exotic
locations available
enjoy cultural exchanges with the locals
and slay away your worries
slaycation paradise is the only
trans-dimensional travel agency to offer
fully inclusive slang moments
our catalog of premium weapons and
defenses provides you with the best and
most inclusive slaycation experiences
throughout the multiverse
getting dismembered by zombies has never
been so much fun kids love it
uh oh looks like little johnny here is
about to be eviscerated
not to worry our state-of-the-art
respanomatic brings you back from
death's door good as new
[Music]
when exploring the world of apocalyptic
disasters it's also important to stay
well fueled
visit the last stop for a refreshing
lumpy gregory cocktail after your tour
and don't forget to gear up for another
fun family trip where will you visit
next
slaycation paradise come slay with us
your suffering will be legendary
do you want to see something scary
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone today we'd like to show you
the development progress of our game
void train it's a sandbox survival game
in which you build and defend your
inter-dimensional train while traveling
across the void full of islands and
obscure creatures you can play at solo
or an online co-op with up to three
friends at your side
with our latest update railroad duel you
will meet enemy trains and outposts for
now reckless nazis have only one simple
goal the destruction of your train
in the next update coming this spring
we're going to bring enemy ai to a whole
new level as they will use different
tactics to steal your valuable resources
and objects so stay vigilant
to fight back you will need advanced
weapons
in voidtrain you can customize weaponry
and add special elemental damage like
fire or shock to your guns
in the future we'll bring an even bigger
variety of weapon modules into the game
void train is currently available in
early access on epic game store and is
coming to more platforms later this year
see you out there in the void
hello all i'm one of the developers on
skates and i want to welcome you to the
first dev vlog focused purely on the
bullet hell mechanics and skates
if you're not familiar with scathe it's
an intense blood-soaked fps where quick
reflexes are the key to surviving the
bullet hell labyrinth that stands
between you and your ascension
rip through the underworld's deadliest
demons and collect the hellstones with
drop in drop out online co-op gameplay
first up all three of us at damage state
and the gang at quality want to say a
big thank you to everyone who played the
teaser demo during the steam next fest
it's been fantastic to see such a
positive reaction and the buzz around it
above this it's been incredible to hear
your feedback and i want to let you know
that we've already acted on it and made
improvements based on it
now back to the bullet hell mechanics
many of you will be familiar with bullet
hell
most likely from 2d game scene perhaps
vertical scrollers like ikaruga side
scrollers even modern gems like cuphead
while they're challenging and visually
entertaining it's less common to see
them in 3d and we wanted to embrace that
in scale because we felt it's a great
fit
we wanted to invite the idea of
navigating the world and dodging the
bullets within it or keeping demon
killing familiar
much like a true bullet hell game it
means you need to keep moving and even
if the demon is dead the projectiles
could still be a threat coming towards
you
as a player you can move dash through
them and in some cases jump though as
it's 3d the vertical z-axis needs to be
considered too
it's been quite challenging bringing the
concept to health shooter as it breaks
an expectation set by others that you
need to be as close as possible to a
demon rather than keeping it at bay
this twist brings a new mindset to the
genre and allows for varying gameplay
and level design
balance of course has been an important
part of the iterative design
naturally you can't spam the screen as
especially in 3d it leaves you with
nowhere to move into
so it's become a careful process of
finding how much is too much
this coupled with explosive chasers a
blend of easy and difficult demons using
land sea and air all makes for an
intense sometimes frantic but fun
variation on the classic hell fps
that's all for this dev vlog on bullet
health
scathe is an ongoing work in progress
and we have lots to share down the line
until then thanks for listening keep the
feedback coming and talk to you soon
[Music]
these disappearances are getting out of
hand
the police reports show a linear growth
at the start but
over the past few weeks it's growing
exponentially
the bright side is
more cases means more evidence
i've been digging through the files and
i
i noticed these symbols
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
those last few games creeped me out it
was great to see that a new version of
mother gunship is being released justin
what do we have next within the last 10
years of curating and producing the mix
showcases and 12 years of production
under my belt one thing is evident
making games is tough sometimes
development takes teams years of hard
work and perseverance to share their
creativity with the world that being
said the next segment is dedicated to
alumni developers who have showcased
their games with the mix before and have
updates new trailers or releases just
around the corner
salute to these mix alumni and their
games
[Music]
my name is brad johnson and this is
demon's mirror
demon's mirror has a unique battle
system that brings a fresh take to
strategic roguelike deck building
you take on the role of a lost soul
who's been trapped in a perpetual loop
inside an inexplicable mirror
your goal is to figure out how to break
the loop and free yourself of this
nightmare
this journey will present many
challenges including plenty of battles
with unforgiving enemies let's take a
look at how combat with an enemy works
like other deck builders you can play
cards to attack and defend against your
opponent but where demon's mirror shines
is in its chain 3 mechanic it's easy to
use but requires lots of practice to
master
at your disposal is a board filled with
different tile types chain tiles
together by clicking and dragging
through similar types completing a chain
will allow you to gain shield collect
essence fill your willpower meter and
best of all to deal massive damage to
enemies
essence is used by certain cards to make
them more powerful
if you collect enough willpower crystals
it will trigger a special event that
lets you choose to do various things
like buff yourself or deal a big chunk
of damage
chaining tiles and playing cards both
use the same pool of action points
you're only given a limited number of
them each turn so it's up to you to
decide what you want to spend them on
playing cards will let you attack defend
gain new abilities and most importantly
manipulate the board
some cards will let you destroy tiles or
add a universal tile
both of those actions will let you make
longer and stronger chains than you
could before
besides directly attacking and defending
enemies can add threatening tiles to the
board
enemy tiles can affect the battle in
many different ways for instance the
tile the enemy just created will launch
and deal 80 damage to you in 5 turns
there are a few ways to deal with enemy
tiles you could wait for the tile to
launch and pray you have enough shield
to block it
but usually a safer strategy is to go on
the offensive and damage or destroy the
tile
certain cars will damage enemy tiles
directly
or you can chain them with other tiles
damaging enemy tiles will cause them to
deal less damage however if you get its
potency down to zero it will be
completely destroyed
demon's mirror has rogue-like elements
so each game you play will be different
choose the path you take find and loot
gobs of treasure
seek out and purchase game changing
items from the shopkeeper who smiles too
much and encounter dreamlike events
use everything at your disposal to
survive your quest to overcome what's in
the demon's mirror coming to pcs later
this year wish list the game now
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
when you begin your coromon journey
you'll be provided with many different
options when it comes to both difficulty
and customization coremon features five
difficulty settings four of which are
preset difficulties while the fifth is a
complete array of custom settings that
will allow you to specifically cater the
game to your play style on the preset
side we have an easy mode which will
recover health on level up have the
price of items in the shop and allow for
healing items to revive fainted coromon
normal mode has no special rules and is
the recommended difficulty setting for
newcomers hard mode adds coremon
permadeath upon fainting though do note
that coramond can be retrieved by
lowering the difficulty setting later
this setting also disallows escape from
wild battles and finally we have insane
mode which includes the hard difficulty
settings and only allows for one capture
per route with the exception of course
being perfect cora mod it also disallows
the use of teleporting items as you can
see each of these difficulty options are
specifically catered to different types
of players if you're looking for
something on the more casual side you
can play on easy or normal and if you
want something more similar to a
nuzlocke run you can play on hard or
insane over to the custom mode option
these can be broken down into three
categories easier game settings harder
game settings and randomization settings
easier settings just allow for more
customization and toggles for the perks
added in the previously mentioned easy
mode preset harder settings allow you to
specifically customize some of the
harder options and has a few settings
including toggles for the presets for
hard and insane mode but also fun stuff
like restricting what you can capture
you can set it to wild core mod only you
could set it to only trainer quorum on
or both and you could even limit how
many visits you can make to a trainer
hub in order to heal finally we have the
random settings which are unlocked by
defeating voltgar the first boss of the
game these allow for a huge amount of
variance between playthroughs you could
choose to randomize all enemy trainer
quorum on all core month skills all wild
koramon koremon traits evolution paths
items including those found and in
quests and a whole lot more there are
also sub settings for some of these as
well for example you can choose whether
or not you want a random evolution to
allow for the quorum on to evolve into a
lesser stage core month or if you still
want them to improve by evolving into a
higher stage core model all in all
coramon offers far more options than
most games in the genre this finally
allows players to choose settings that
best fit them allowing for an insane
amount of customization and
replayability
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone my name is mickey and i'm
producer of sewer cleaners here at draw
distance we're a polish studio based in
krakow
we're known for serial cleaner and
vampire the masquerade visual novels
right now we're working on silver
cleaners which is being published by 505
games we also have several other
projects cooking they will be revealed
when the time comes
what you'll see today is serial cleaner
on steroids new york city in the 90s
four playable characters and story with
a twist
if you remember the 90s differently
their duty work is the reason why
this is cereal cleaners
today let's focus on serial cleaners a
sequel with basquiat and street art
inspired graphics reactive cops and a
soundtrack deeply rooted in the 90s it's
a true nostalgia trip for everyone who
remembers it and a box full of surprises
for everyone else
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
shout out to all of the mix alumni
orbital bullet was released just
yesterday and we will have more updates
on the website also make sure to check
out the updates on the steam page as
well as wish list the games and support
the developers with some love now for
our final segment we're going to slide
into some narrative story based action
adventure titles first we'll go out to
sea with a gorgeous new title called
submerge in in depth then get into some
underwater exploration with silt we'll
wrap things up with a tiny yet
gargantuan adventure with small land
we'll be right back after these dope
trailers see you soon
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's hope this will finally get us out
of this junkyard and bam
come on
there's nothing to turn around
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi my name's dom and i'm the technical
director at spiral circus games
hi i'm tom and i'm the art director at
spiral circus games
today we're going to show you some
exclusive gameplay footage from our
debut game silt
here we find ourselves swimming through
a dense underwater forest
we come across a strange creature living
in a solitary tree in the middle of a
large clearing
the creature seems to want something
from us
maybe it's asking for food
let's swim down see if we can find
something for it
silt is a 2d puzzle adventure game set
in a surreal underwater world
you play as a diver who wakes up alone
and trapped with no choice other than to
travel further into the abyss
this dark dense undergrowth is home to a
large number of leeches
these leeches can grab onto the diver
and deal damage and you can be quickly
overwhelmed if you're not careful
the leech leeches instinctively flee
from bright lights so can be kept at bay
with the diver's lamp
moving further ahead we find a small
school of bulb fish
these creatures use the bright lights
that emit from their heads to keep the
leeches at a safe distance
[Music]
the bulb fish have a more playful and
inquisitive nature they seem to want to
follow the diver
if we move slowly and keep them nearers
they might keep us safe from the leeches
for a while
[Music]
at the very bottom of this tunnel we
come across what the creature in the
tree wanted from us
it's a big juicy grub
the grub clamps onto our head disabling
our headlamp if we didn't have these
bulb fish around us the leeches would be
closing in and we'd be done for
[Music]
now we must carefully make our way back
to the entrance of the tunnel and
deliver the grove to the creature in the
tree
[Music]
if we move slowly and carefully we can
maintain this formation of bulb fish
around us and hopefully make it back to
the entrance unharmed
the key to navigating silts murky abyss
is carefully observing the creatures
around you and using their abilities to
your own advantage
silt will be available to buy later this
year and if you like what you've seen so
far you can head over to steam and add
it to your wishlist
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello to everyone at the mix showcase
i'm danny the community manager at
merged games and i'm with ross who's the
product manager on small land hello
we're going to show you some gameplay
from small land today so here's ross
starting out early game to talk you
through yes so this is just where you
come out of the cave and i'm just about
to speak to the elder who gives you your
very first quests
and now they come on and basically one
of the quest that leads to is knock
which is your game play danny
yeah so knox is one of the pathfinders
who are the members of your race who've
gone out ahead scouted the land and
they've got some quests for you that are
going to teach you a bit about the world
and systems apply in small land
yeah so there's a series of npcs and
we've actually covered those in some
steam posts and there's a couple of npcs
as well which sort of allude to some of
the equipment you can unlock and
know better bows better swords etc and
so one of the things we have now is we
have quite a late game quest and to do
that we need to do some prep so whilst i
was scavenging for resources danny was
doing some nice uh home building
yeah so you'll you'll make your main
base up in the trees of small land but
you can build anywhere in the land and
you can make a really nice little
forward camp for when you're out
exploring adventuring and you want
people to be able to personalize and
decorate these houses and you can see
here nice bit of lighting and you can
decorate the interior of it
customization's really important to us
here is a much bigger build that i built
later and one of the great things is
that your friends can join your join
your world and come and explore and this
is where ross has come to have a look
around what i've built yeah so like
danny says i'm just having a wee peek
around trying to pill for any resources
he has checking out some of the trophies
there and like i said it's one of the
great things about smalling you know we
encourage people to be creative with
their builds and so having people build
their home away from home it's really
enjoyable to see people like what what
people can come up with so danny's built
this massive base so what i'm doing now
is i'm waiting for the tool rack which i
have and i'm going to create some armor
now because we like i mentioned we have
a late game quest so what we're going to
do now is do some prep get ready and
then we're going to go hunting for some
uh insects
so later game ross and i have come to
the road biome because we know that's
where the sun flies i was doing a
one-to-one battle as you do and then
ross kite it in a lot more trouble i
tried to nope out of it but they
followed me across the road so i saw
danny and i thought he could help me
and so we were taking on the flies and
then we were about to defeat them and
then of course a cockroach came along
and now the thing about cockroaches is
you can see in the bottom right where
basically they have like a toxicity uh
that's where the armor comes in handy
because the bee sting makes you sort of
resilient to those sorts of things but
of course you still take like physical
damage so once that happened um you're
about to see basically where my
character dies um but you know combat is
very much part of a survival game yeah
and there's lots of things in small land
that can and will kill you
but but we we hope you've enjoyed this
little look into the world of small land
we've got so much more to show you and
we can't wait to show you more about the
game
thanks everyone
and that is a wrap 80 plus dope games
from this year's 10th year anniversary
showcase we appreciate you tuning in
with us and all of the developers who
showcased and all of our partners as
well shout out to our sponsors limited
run games raw fury razor for providing
pcs for our production and more thanks
to all of the publishers and developers
who have supported the stream through
their sponsorship as well as
participating in the showcase in general
we hope to see you all in person this
week it has been two years but we are
having a showcase in person with limited
run games i can't wait shout out to our
broadcasting partners twitch gaming ign
game spotted valve we couldn't do it
without your support also make sure to
connect with the intel game dev boost
program which helps devs get technical
support visibility amplification and
discoverability for their games
and don't forget to check out the mix
10th anniversary showcase page on steam
where you can learn more about the games
buy games that are available now or add
games to your wish list for games that
haven't been released yet these
wishlists really help the devs so please
don't forget to do that make sure to do
that if you want to support us make sure
to grab some mixed swag shirts stickers
and all that good stuff on our roboroba
merch page and get dripped out and
draped up
thanks to wilmer sound we're in their
beautiful soundstage and facility right
now uh the mix team media one
productions timmy abe cope 32 fully
illustrated and everyone else who helped
out with the production of this event
you can follow me at icj man on twitter
and the mix at indiexchange on twitter
and media in the exchange on instagram
and facebook now make sure to stay tuned
because right after this show we're
gonna head over to our live broadcast of
black voices and gaming stream
showcasing amazing games from black game
developers it's gonna be so dope it's
gonna be great thank you so much for
joining me danny it's been a pleasure
thanks for having me it's always fun
being here thank you so much for sure
thanks to all of you for tuning in we
will see you really soon
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you